はい！えと、今ちょっと...
外から帰ってきたんですけども
今日は非常に緊急事態です。
今、普通の顔してるんですけども
実は.........
財布を無くしてるんだ！(-ω☆)キラリ.
友達と大道芸コンテストに行ったんですけども
行く途中において
こうなんか無くしてしまって...財布を...
家に帰ってきたら、財布がないことに気づいて
犯人は君？（隣にいる友達に）
（友達）違う違う
でかい荷物があったから
タクシーで行ったんですけども
もう、帰ってきた時点で気づいたから
どこで落としたかっていうのがわかんない
カバンは？
ねぇ、とったでしょ！？
（友達）とってない、とってない
じゃあ、見せてよ！
（友達）タクシー代払ったじゃん、俺が
あ、そっか(*ﾟ∇ﾟ)ﾉ
友達のリュックにたぶん入ってるかもしんないです
ほら！！！！！！
（友達）俺んのじゃん！俺んの (○´艸｀)ヾ
これ！
(友達)ばかたれ！
探して無いってことは
タクシーか道で落としたからね
とりあえず、タクシーの会社に電話します
これで、無いですって言われたらほんとにアウト
すみません、えっと、先ほどタクシーを利用したものなんですけども
（タクシー会社）はいはい
なんか、ちょっと財布を無くしちゃったみたいで
いや、なんか
ちょっ
はい
（タクシー会社）ちょっと待っててくだいさいね
（タクシー会社）聞いてみますので
は、はーい
♪～θ(´∀｀★)(★´∀｀)θ～♪
♫咲かせることだ〜けに
♫いっしょうけっ...
あっ、はーい///
もしもし
(タクシー会社)調べてもらったけどないってことですけどね
(タクシー会社)どこかで落としちゃったってことはないかな
えっ
(タクシー会社)車の中には無いみたいですよ
本当ですか？
(タクシー会社)えぇ...
(タクシー会社)今、調べさせたんですけどね
あっ、本当ですか
(タクシー会社)えぇ...
なんか、もし見つかったりしたら
おしえていただけると有り難いです
ありがとうございます
まじ落とした
まじ落とした（二回目）
（友達）まじ、やばいやばいやばい
やばい
公園か、降りた瞬間か
えっとさっき確認したタクシーっていうのは
今乗せてもらったタクシーだけですかね？
僕たぶん、行きの時なくしちゃったみたいで
あー、なるほどなるほど
あっ、分かりました
何時頃になりそうか分かりますかね？
8時... はい。分かりました。
じゃあその時間またよろしくお願いします。
すいません
はい。それでは失礼します
なんかさっきの電話はなんか...
帰ってきたタクシー
だけを確認されたみたいなんですけども
行きのタクシーでなくしたっぽいので
そこも今確認してもらってます
とりあえず、コンテストの会場に行って探してみます
はい！というわけで
大道芸コンテストの会場にやってきました訳なんですけども
あっ、食べる？
（友達）あっ、ありがと！
メインイベントはここからっすよ！
無くした財布を見つけるという訳で
早速ちょっと探していこうとおもいます
なんか食う？
(友達)もう閉まってるよね
ラーメン食いたかったな
(友達)ラーメン？本当だあった
ロボットダンスかましてくるわ
(友達)本当に？
うん。
(友達)まじで？
刮目せよ！
(-_☆)キラーン!!
やきそばで300円でしょ？
(友達)500円だったのが、
(友達)なんか300円でいいよって言われたもんで
500円だったの！
落ちてる可能性が一番高いから地面におとしてみます
かつ
8時ごろにひょっとしたらタクシー会社から電話がかかってくるかも...
あっ、タクシー会社から電話がかかってきてる
あのすいません。えっと...
先ほど財布無くしたって言ってた者なんですけど
(タクシー会社)財布の件ですね
(タクシー会社)今乗務員がね...
はい分かりました。
そこらへんで
(タクシー会社）巽櫓でいいですか？
はい
(タクシー会社)じゃあ、そのように伝えます
はい。すみません
ありがとございます
見つかったね
落としたんじゃなくて
タクシーの中にあったみたいなんですけど
たつみやぐらぁ？
巽櫓ってとこにタクシーの人が来てくれるから
とりあえず、そこまで向かいましょう
すいません
（タクシーの人）ほらちょっと確認して...
（タクシーの人）みて
（タクシーの人）もし間違えあったら大変だから
全然...
全然大丈夫です。すいませんありがとうございます。
ほんと助かりました。ありがとうございます。
（タクシーの人）いえいえ
（タクシーの人）ありがとう
ありがとうございます
(ﾉω･､) ｳｩ･･･
はい！という訳で、無事
財布が戻って来ました
タクシーの方が優しい人でほんとに助かりました
お疲れぃ！
えいっ！
お疲れーぃ！うぇーい!!
お疲れーぃ！
(友達)アンパンマン状態やん
みんな友達みたいになっちゃってる
この時間でも
ほんと誰もいないっすよ今
全然この時間でも人いるよ
(友達)8時30分ぐらいじゃない？
うぇい！お疲れぃ！
うえーい！お疲れぃ！
うえーーい！お疲れぃ！
はい！お疲れぃ！
（周りの人）はじめじゃん！
はじめじゃん！！
はじめじゃん!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
ﾀﾀﾀﾀｧεεεεεヾ(*´・ω・`)ﾉ